the mountainside is a mass of tents pock
marked with illegal mining shafts and
mounds and mounds of dead grey soil
the forest which was once here is now
long gone and unlikely ever to return
instead there are men like ali doing
probably the most dangerous job in
madagascar today
they are desperate men turning to
desperate ways to survive
he and his team have dug this tunnel out
by hand the flimsy plastic tube
alongside him is taking the only air
that will keep them alive down here
within seconds the surface and safety as
well as light is left behind
it's jet black without his head torch
he has no protective gear at all and is
inching his way down in his bare feet
it takes all two minutes to be lowered
down the tunnel
he and his two other friends are now
more than 70 meters down crawling in a
space just big enough to take them
without a support beam in sight
they're digging for gems which they hope
will change their lives forever and haul
them out of poverty
trouble is the last time they found
anything of any note was eight months
ago a piece of barrel they sold for two
millionaires about five hundred dollars
split amongst the team of seven
not exactly the fortune they're dreaming
of
above ground lux is in charge of the
most important job his main task is
ensuring airs pumped continuously down
the shaft
but they're working with crude
inadequate material and ali's not down
there long before the vital airbag
splits what's happened is they're broken
now for sure he'll be having trouble
breathing his colleague tells us as the
team tries to patch together the
lifeline with tape
underground the break in the air supply
is rapidly noticed
but the lack of panic seems to indicate
this is a fairly regular potentially
deadly hazard they often pass out down
here but it doesn't put them off
i'm always brave with my work his friend
replies
all around them there's equally risky
but continuous activity
around 6 000 people are working here
alone
all this spawns a multi-million dollar
smuggling racket and black market in
madagascar
little of which makes its way into these
miners pockets but which massively
contributes to deforestation affects
wildlife and weather patterns as well as
the climate
this is just one illegal encampment in
one part of the country there are an
estimated half a million people who are
taking part in illegal mining if you
look here you can see it goes on for
some distance that would make it the
second biggest employer in the whole of
madagascar and more and more people are
being driven into it because of poverty
and of course that has a big impact on
the habitat
the miners are strikingly positive
despite their lack of success and the
frayed equipment they rely on doesn't
seem to influence their nerves
ali and his crew are unperturbed by the
dangers or the impact on their
homeland's precious environment any laws
preventing this illegal mining are
unenforced
they've all spent all their lives doing
this and say they've no alternative
i'm not afraid at all he says i'm used
to this work i make my living out of it
and i'm not afraid
[Applause]
but the forests are coming down at an
unrelenting pace in this one of the most
biodiverse nations on earth
this logger told us he expected to bring
down a hundred trees that day and he's
in a team of ten
the trees are used for firewood for
cooking and selling as well as making
way for illegal mining but every loss of
every tree adds carbon dioxide to the
air affecting the climate and
endangering wildlife and again poverty
is the driver
robert will make ten dollars today
five times more than most of his fellow
citizens the bulk of whom are living
below the poverty line
back at the illegal mining site a gem
buyer is driving a hard bargain
no good
there's a crack in it he says
this group of families have been working
five months to collect this amount of
barrel the gem buyer offers five
thousand nariari
there's nothing good here he says but
famer in the lime green shirt is
disgusted he's got 15 relatives to feed
he's being offered just over a dollar
for months of work
he's not selling today
the gem buyer shows us what he considers
good quality precious barrel gems
he reckons he'll get 25 for all this a
fraction of what they'll fetch when
they're turned into rings or earrings
and at an enormous cost to madagascar's
unique environment
alex crawford sky news in madagascar